what's up GQ it's Lil Tech and these are
my essentials
now this is one of my main Essentials
this is my lyric book I wrote most of my
last album in here a lot of the times
when I write songs I like to think about
what I'm going through and it's real
personal to me so it's not like putting
it in my phone notes when I write it
down I don't gotta show nobody no one
can hack that no one could find out
about it I could write anything in here
I even write lyrics in here when I don't
have a beat when I'm not in the studio
so I like to keep it on me all the time
I never know when I might just like
think of some random lines I gotta get
down somewhere this is actually my first
time like
buying a book designated for an album so
looking forward I'm probably gonna do
one every album like a book every album
because after I finish my own I ain't
gonna touch this like I'm probably gonna
put this in like a glass case and
hanging up my wall
[Music]
this right here is so essential this is
Chrome Hearts bag so so so essential and
this is my bag I don't leave the house
without it I don't leave my room without
it ever since I got this bag I just been
carrying it with me everywhere you can
ask me for anything it's probably in
this bag
also this is my Chrome Hearts wallet
chain which is also very very essential
I lose stuff a lot so I like to have
clipped onto my pants all the time I
don't leave the house without it people
offer me different types of money for
this and I'm never selling it ever don't
even offer no more
foreign
if you don't know about this like I said
I do not trust you at all my favorite
games on here is probably midnight club
b-boy
jackass Rainbow Six Siege
Socom or Midnight Club especially I
gotta talk about midnight club if you
know about that game especially the
soundtrack of that game I grew up on
these this is probably like my seventh
PSP I used to break these all the time a
little bit last year I was just playing
my PSP before the shows it was very like
common roasting each other is a very big
part of like Xbox culture and if you
know about them them game chats you know
how we could get you're not even gonna
talk about that on here I could do your
own researches for that roasting people
through Ramen was just another Outlet of
just flaming them like
just had to Flame them and I'm like oh
I could probably do this on Beats
too so I found this app on the app store
called bandlab started downloading
YouTube beats put it up in bandlab Apple
headphones behind the pop filter going
crazy
now this right here
super essential it's just another part
of the swag I always keep one on me I
got it on me right now this is just
extra I'm on my rainbow swag right now
it's just me versus everybody like
I don't know I'm just in that mode
accessories are real big to me so
adding stuff besides just a shirt pants
and boots it's real important to like
finishing the look for me and making it
look full
this is my laptop and this is all my
phones
I'm gonna get into the laptop because
this is like my life this is like
this is everything like this is where my
FL Studio is at my Pro Tools at I record
all my songs on here
I make all my Beats on here
um I edit videos on here like this is
this is this is everything this is like
this is tech for real like this is Tech
like in digital form if I lose this
right here I lose everything
so I keep it on me I don't even want it
in the house even if I'm not in the
house this is my main phone this is like
what I call all my friends on FaceTime
take my flicks on most of the time this
was my old personal phone
this one it's crack spawn off right now
this phone been through it and back I
still use this to this day sometimes
because it got like some of my music
that I don't got on this phone on it
these two is cameras and this one kind
of been through it too I don't like
getting phones fixed I don't know why I
feel like it's breaks it more every time
I got a friend I get their phone fixed
they come back to me like bro my screen
not working two weeks later all this
other stuff like I'm not with it so I
just keep it broken
and we still here
[Music]
I'm always in the studio I'm always on
my feet so
when I'm rocking these uncomfortable
shoes I like to just change it to some
more comfortable and just like I said
keep it stylish everything I got on me
is stylish you see I'm wearing these
after like four or five hours six seven
hours
you're going to want to change into
these
when I get dressed it definitely depends
on how I feel
sometimes I wake up and I just don't
even care I might just wear sweats all
day but sometimes I might
want to switch it up a little bit
sometimes I don't even care if I'm
comfortable I might wear something
uncomfortable just because it's fly
clothes actually makes me feel awake
like I remember going to uniform school
on those Fridays when they used to let
us wear what we wanted
I used to act different on those Fridays
for real so that's what really made me
fall in love with clothes because I'm
like when I get to choose what I'm
wearing I actually like it it's just
another expression of how I'm feeling
like especially when I don't see no one
else rocking when I'm rocking how I'm
rocking it
my most obvious essential
are my glasses I cannot see without my
glasses
these are actually prescribed I don't
know my number or whatever it is you
ever seen that thing in Scooby-Doo where
she lose her glasses and she like
she's like looking for him all over the
floor that's really how I am it's the
biggest glitch for real because you use
them to see but when you don't have them
and you're looking for them you can't
see so it's kind of hard to find them
but
yeah very essential
[Music]
this is my lighter but it's not just my
regular lighter this is my lighter with
my lighter case I got these from none of
your business because if I see one of
y'all walking around with these and I
think it's mine and it's really yours
then we're gonna have a problem y'all
can look it up yeah I probably won't
find it I hope y'all don't get your own
that's one thing get your own why are
you even in a position where you need a
lighter and you don't have one why don't
you have a lighter why you leave the
house without a lighter why you link up
with me without a lighter you might get
this but I'm gonna be watching you the
whole time and I'm gonna ask for it back
yo bro you got that lighter still yo let
me get that back bro I'm gonna get it
back
now this right here essential when my
lips is dry I literally go crazy like I
can't talk to no one I can't eat no food
I don't want to hear you talk I just
need some of this right here if you
don't got this on you I probably don't
trust you I always got it only you could
borrow mine shout out Vaseline man
now hold it down
on stage when I'm on stage I always got
water next to me you never know like you
might have hit that high note that song
after you might have like a five second
transition you gotta open the powder
real quick refill but I don't really
like care about the whole water stuff
the whole water brand the whole all of
that but I actually like Essentia
essential if y'all see this y'all rock
with me I rock with child for sure the
bottle is getting consumed
[Music]
my name is loteca thank you for stepping
into my Essential world this all my
must-haves with me
take the album out now GQ subscribe turn
notifications
[Music]